hey everyone my name is jacob lariviere
i am an economist in the office of the
chief economist at microsoft thanks for
attending this session
i'm going to spend a little bit of time
talking about how i think causal machine
learning
can have good impact some opportunities
to grow and then how to make it really
scale based upon my experience
of six years at microsoft
so here's an example of where
uh causal ml is having some real good
impact and so let's say that you're
in the productivity app business and
you're trying to figure out how should i
structure my app and what features
should i have in my app to make it as
awesome as possible so that people like
it so let's say that you're
working at outlook and you think well
maybe i should have my search bar to
search through my email at the top maybe
it should be further down like closer to
where the actual emails are well you
could do this using experimentation you
could say well let's put it in one
location that'll be treatment a another
location that's treatment b
have some experimentation try and infer
what's better than the other
and they've done that and there are
capabilities that that for that but not
every feature is sort of hooked up to
that experimentation platform
and so for features that aren't it turns
out that device machine learning or
double machine learning can recover
experimental uh estimates
of new or augmented features in an app
so this is an example where you have a
rich feature set lots of observations
and the device machine learning does a
terrific job at recovering your
experimental experimental estimates
so
unfortunately we're not all the way
there with cosml and there's some
opportunities to do a little bit better
and so here's a sharp example and
there's a whole class of examples that
that fall here
and this is about compliers so let's say
that you're a business and you have a
new offer or you have a new product and
you're trying to figure out what's the
impact of that product on downstream
revenue or on upsell or something like
that and so you're trying to say well
for the people that adopt this product
or take up this offer i want to estimate
what their impact is relative to a
control
group or a control
user that doesn't uh uptake the offer
in that situation you're going to look
at your compliers in this graph you can
see them in blue
and then you're going to you know mine
through all your folks and try and find
some say selected controls
and you're going to try and match them
up look at the difference after the
offer is available compare compliers to
your sort of selected controls and see
how you do
now the challenge with this is that most
people that work in business know that
anytime that you have a special offer
the types of people that uptake that
special offer are the same types of
peoples that have sort of this big ramp
up in their usage right beforehand so it
looks like there's a lot of positive
selection not just in terms of higher
average usage but also in that immediate
pre-period before somebody complies to
an offer there's this ramp up and so if
we're trying to figure out what the
average treatment effect for compliers
is and there's this pre-compliance ramp
i'm wondering if there's a scalable
falsification test that causal
machine learning could could help us
um
develop
so
i think this is sort of an open area for
research i'm actively working with a
another person in our group trying to
figure out if there's sort of these
scalable falsification tests to
understand how well your controls are
are doing compared to your compliers
um open question and so i would love to
see progress along this front and if you
don't like this particular example with
squiggly lines you can have a different
example where you have smoother lines
both of these figures i should say are
real data i've obviously removed the
axes but in both pictures you can see
that there's this pre-period ramp in the
in the green right before somebody sort
of complies and either you know
subscribes to
a subscription service or say
um starts
you know using an offer that the
business has put it put into play
and so on my wish list is a scalable
falsification test that would be part of
a cosm causal ml package that would help
uh help people and help businesses try
and uh
put their resources in the right place
so finally really quick wrapping up
so if something like this were to work
at scale to to assess like say
how what's the causal effect of
compliance on
on usage of an app or on downstream
revenue or something like that
for any of the stuff to work at scale
there's got to be real engineering uh
work that goes in and so i can imagine
something that would be a similar setup
to an experimentation platform where
there's an a b scheduler
that
that can be automated but here you're
going to be looking at complier status
so you're going to have to have your
marketing
data set that lists
complier status and that has to be fed
into sort of your uber data set which is
going to have the types of features that
you would match on
or the outcomes that you would match on
if you're doing a synthetic controls
type approach
in order to do something like this where
you would have like a causal ml package
that's trying to to help you estimate
the average treatment effect on the
treated you're gonna need to have a
business partner who's willing to invest
that could be marketing finance or maybe
it's a research or applied science
organization i think it's doable
but we just don't quite have the tool to
do it and then lastly there is a hard
business conversation about which use
cases are the most valuable because
obviously those are going to have the
highest expected benefit relative to
cost of investing so thank you very much
hope this was useful looking forward to
the conversation